i think that we should get you like a
little you know corset so that way you
have a wasp waist
and i just went oh
no i don't i don't like that one i don't
think so and she went
what why and i was like oh a reason
a reason what would you do if there were
mice
learning all around us is so dead
i would call the exterminator you see
girls he would exterminate those brats
so um just to jump right in you know in
the devil wears prada
stanley was kind of like a mentor to you
and this one you couldn't be more
dismissive of him
how fun was it for you guys to get to
reunite and kind of go toe-to-toe on
screen again
oh it was such a joy i was so happy when
i found out that stanley was going to
be in the movie because devil was proud
it was such a special experience
like and then it's become this touchdown
movie
for so many people yes we love it uh
it might fit it might okay now chanel
you're in desperate need of chanel
darling shall we we have to get to the
beauty department and god knows how long
that's going to take but
for us making it it was it was such a
joy and i think in all of our careers a
highlight
and so so to get to pick up with stanley
and get to play totally different
characters and get to be weird and silly
uh it was really special enjoy babies a
really good giggle
i really enjoyed them like i loved the
book so much i didn't know if i would
enjoy the movie as much but i did i
loved it so much good
that that is we love hearing that thing
so you were expecting your second son
jack when you were on set and did they
have to kind of
figure out different ways with the grand
high witch with a wardrobe or anything
or were you
like well we just kind of went about the
same way bro
we you know i um
[Music]
no but with one exception i didn't
really tell anybody that i was pregnant
because i was still in my first
trimester so
and then when i uh when i went into my
second trimester during filming i only
told a couple people but
the costume still fits so i didn't feel
the need to tell anybody
right off the bat joanna johnson who was
a legend
and a genius or costume designer she
was telling me about what she wanted the
character to look like and everything
she was saying was perfect she was
describing the gloves and the gloves
having these little nail inserts and
how she wanted you know and and the
fabric she was going to use and the
silhouettes and
everything was just great and i think
that we should get you like a little
you know corset so that you have a wasp
waste and i just went oh
no i don't i don't like that one i don't
think so and she went
what why and i was like oh a reason
a reason and i couldn't say because i'm
five weeks pregnant and now i just
and i'm like just just i mean tap
dancing i cannot think of a thing to say
and i go i just know myself as a
performer
and i'm just gonna feel really
constrained i'm gonna feel really
constrained and i just i'm gonna be
funnier
if i don't have something i love you i
love you so much
yes it's such a yes but somehow i sold
it and joanna didn't ask questions and
she worked with me
and then by by the end of the movie i
was 16 weeks pregnant and she got it
by the way have you i mean with two
babies now have you actually enjoyed
this slow down
period a bit i mean giving you time to
like chill out or
because you're always on the go so i
wonder if it's been like constraining or
good i feel very obnoxious talking about
my silver linings because you know
we've all had very different covert
experiences and i think mine was
probably amongst the least painful
but it i did enjoy being with my family
and then
and it was that for me and um yeah
and there were there were there were a
lot of silver linings for me in it
okay can we talk about that
transformation bts video that had me
like i think i watched it at
that time lapse i don't know how many
times i was obsessed with that
how long did that actually take it
wasn't that bad it was about 45 minutes
maybe a little bit less and it would
have been shorter except i got stuck
what do you mean you got stuck like they
couldn't get it off you
he couldn't get me out of it so
i knew so like i they kind of went to
pull it off and nothing happened and i
knew
and then everybody got very silent and i
thought something's gone very wrong here
but eventually we kind of went through
it little by little and we pulled it off
and i had all my eyelashes at the end
which was the one thing i had been
worried about so uh so it was all good
another time when i'd had a when i had a
face
cast done they missed a spot on my nose
they're supposed to put the solution on
to keep it help it slide off and they
missed
my nose and when they pulled it off it
like
really did some damage and i wound up
getting two black eyes
so this one was like a walk in the park
this one wasn't it wasn't wasn't that
bad
well you're good because i would have
had anxiety for days
being in that thing i don't think i
think you would be i think you'd have
surprised yourself because when you're
doing it for something you love
and it's something that you know that
you do it's not like like someone just
springs it on you
you know and i knew that i was working
with like the best in the business
and if it was gonna go well it would be
going well with those guys so
it was okay ladies i have a plan
hundred the transform a child into a
mouse
so which of the witch-isms would annoy
you most in life the claws for hands
not having toes or that like the mouth
that's from here to here
i like to eat so i think the mouth would
work and
i think i think it must be very hard to
open jars
with only with only the three and i
don't like asking people to do things
for me
um so i think probably the the three
hands
yeah the fingers well of course we know
um
angelica houston was the grand high
witch of all grand high witches and
did you want to pay some homage to her
when you were doing this or did you want
to just really kind of
chart your own path
[Music]
locked and bolded both
yeah i wanted to i wanted to give a
performance that was
that that felt as memorable to uh the
children of today as her performance
meant
felt to me and i knew there was that
opportunity there but i it also felt
like it would have been
in a way disrespectful to to to crib her
performance
hers is hers and and it was for nick
rogues
brilliant movie and mine was mine and it
was for
robert zemeckis you know and um and so i
felt very comfortable that they were
going to be two very very different
performances
and i always you know and i kept and any
moments that i felt like a little
nervous about are people going to let
there be two grand high witches
in film history i just went you know
what people have got people in the last
30 years there have been four jokers
there you go there have been six batman
there have been i
don't know how many james bonds like
people can do this we're just not used
to doing it with actresses but
great then we should then it's time to
learn i was gonna say we shouldn't have
those same questions for
for female roles that because we don't
have them for male roles
i'm not i'm not crazy right like no
you're not at all
you're not at all did you ever did you
get a chance to connect with her do you
know
if she's seen it or will will see it
or can you even think about that i
haven't let myself go there yet
that was the one thing i didn't always
think about i was just like
maybe not even maybe but all i just want
is her to be in john wick four
that's what i'm pulling for so that's
what i can't wait to see
you